Now, today is lecture 2.
And we're going to be
talking about counting.
And we're going to be talking
about the mul which is a way
to count to help us count.
And then-- and this
is really exciting--
we're going to be building this.
And that is super exciting.
Now, everybody
should have gotten
one of these on
the first day when
we talk about this
later in the lecture.
If you don't have this,
and for that matter--
oh, there's Laura.
Laura has like
thousands of these.
And if you need one,
please ask Laura.
And also if you
need a goodie bag,
which we gave out
on the first day,
please get in touch with Laura.
And she'll give you one.
We have extras here.
You can stop by our office
later, get one please today.
All right, now, last
lecture, we left off with--
remember, those guys like Boyle
and Priestley and Lavoisier,
conservation of mass, right?
And what these
guys were doing is
they were smashing and
burning and pushing on things
and trying to figure
out what it was
that was that sort
of fundamental object
that you couldn't
break apart anymore.
And remember, it was
Democritus that said
there is such a thing, right?
He said there was a such a
thing called atoms, "atomos".
And so we come to
Dalton, who said,
look, these things
we're trying, we're
calling them elements right now.
Let's, in honor of that
indivisibility idea,
let's call them atoms.
And Dalton did a lot of
really important experiments.
And he was also trying to
smash and break and measure
and figure out what
are these indivisible--
and what are these things that
you can't break apart any more?
What are these atoms?
How many of them are there?
What do they do?
And he came up with a
pretty important observation
which was that he called it the
law of multiple proportions.
And in this, so what
Dalton did is he said,
look, I'm going to take
something and react it
with something else.
And it's going to react fully.
OK, so there's no
limiting reagent.
There's no excess.
It just everything reacted
here and everything
and want to measure
how much stuff reacts.
And then how much I get.
And so if you take
like an example
of this law of
multiple proportions,
if you take an example
of how that came about,
what he observed is that if
you had sort of, for example,
maybe you had sort of case one.
And you react some amount.
So he's going to
react some amount.
So let's say he reacted--
OK, I don't know, some amount.
Let's write it.
Yeah, some amount of
something, maybe, carbon.
And some amount
of something else.
How about oxygen?
And he would get
some amount, right?
OK, we know he's doing
all these measurements.
I'm trying to get you
back in that mood.
How much do I have?
I'm going to weigh
it, measure it.
That's what he's
doing over and over.
But he had some
amount of something.
Aha.
Now, he would do this
over and over again.
OK, I'm just taking these
two elements as an example.
He did this for many,
many elements, right?
So some amount of
carbon with salmonella.
And in case one, OK,
everything reacts.
And I get this carbon to
oxygen mass ratio of let's say
1 to 1.33.
I measure it.
That's how much of
the sum amount, right?
1 to 1.33 reacts fully.
Remember, no excess, because
they add a little more,
and it's excess.
No, this reacts fully.
And then you do
it, again, case 2.
And he'd find that this
same ratio was 1 to 2.66.
Ha, ha.
And he noticed a pattern.
And he called it the
law multiple portions,
because what he found is
that you could keep on going.
And in some cases,
not all cases.
But in some cases,
like carbon and oxygen,
for example, these were
common ratios, these series.
2.66 divided by
1.33 is an integer.
These things would happen in
integer ratios, integer amount.
So I could keep going, and
maybe I'd get three or four.
Right?
And what that
means is that well,
over here, this sum
amount of something
is it said something
about the something,
right, because it says maybe
these somethings are like CO
and CO2, right, for example.
Maybe, aha, but not definitely.
And that frustrated Dalton.
That frustrated him.
We'll come back
to that in a sec.
Right?
But he did this.
And he observed these
ratios, these integer ratios
of what would react with what--
he's trying to figure out
what is he making?
All right, what is he making?
Now, he also, as with
Lavoisier, remember,
I showed you
Lavoisier's tableau.
Well, he had his own table.
And here it is.
So here in 1827, he had
identified 36 elements.
Now, the thing is,
though, OK, 0.1,
if you're going to try to brand
something, which he clearly
tried with these
symbols, you can't make
them this complicated, right?
I'm pretty happy that that's
not how we write our elements.
You can see that this
would be very hard.
But he did come up
with these symbols.
And you can see it would
be very hard to keep going
without getting [inaudible].
So I think we're pretty lucky
that [? brazilious ?] came
along and figured out how
to name these elements
in a consistent way.
But that wasn't
his real problem.
His real problem was
what I just alluded to.
See, he knew that he had
these different elements.
But he didn't know what
the compositions were.
He was so close.
He could see that these--
ah, but is it CO and CO2?
Or is it CO2 and CO4?
That he didn't know.
That he didn't know, because
he didn't have an accurate way
to measure the mass of an
atom, not at that time.
But he did have this nice
ability to see these series.
OK.
But in comes other measurements.
And you had Gay-Lussac who
was looking at volumes, right?
And so Gay-Lussac
was saying, well,
look, if I take a certain amount
of volume of a gas, one gas,
and I reacted again
completely, no access, OK?
And I reacted with another gas.
And then I see I get
something else over here.
I can measure the volumes.
And I do this for
the cases where
there's nothing left
over, nothing limited it.
And so he would find, for
example, what's shown up there.
He would find that
you've got for every two
volumes of hydrogen gas--
so you've got two
volumes of hydrogen
that he would react with
one volume of oxygen.
And he would notice
that he would get two
volumes of something that had--
let's not put a dash there--
it had hydrogen
and oxygen in it.
He knew that.
Now, he knew this because
he was very careful.
So nothing leaked.
He said no.
Everything is accounted for.
Lavoisier holds--
conservation of mass.
I'm not losing anything here.
And as Lavoisier said,
in a chemical reaction,
mass is neither
created nor destroyed.
So I know that
whatever is over here
must consist of
whatever I have here--
oxygen and hydrogen.
And he kept doing it
for other lots of
different types of gases.
But it was very strange, because
what happens is sometimes,
the volumes are the same.
Like he did it for
hydrogen and chlorine.
One volume of hydrogen,
and one volume of chlorine
would give you two volumes
of hydrogen and chlorine--
something that had hydrogen
and chlorine in it.
And so there, you'd mix
one and add another one.
And you'd get two.
It seems it would
kind of makes sense.
You add one volume.
But here, you'd mix two
volumes, add another volume.
And it would feel
like it was reduced.
Something in the
reaction happened
that gave you a lower volume.
What could it possibly be?
Right, what was going on.
This is what they
were grappling with.
This is where they were.
And then along comes
[sighs] Avogadro.
Now, I wish we all called him
Lorenzo Romano Amedeo Carlo
Avogadro which is his full name.
But we shall call him Avogadro.
And he made a critical proposal.
He said, look, the
way to explain what's
going on in Gay-Lussac's
volume measurements
is to make the following
assumption-- oh, I
have another board
over here-- is to make
the following assumption.
And I think if you've had
high school chemistry,
you know what this is.
But I'm going to put it here,
because of how important it is.
So Avogadro said that
at constant temperature
and pressure equal volume
equals same number of particles.
So if I have the
[? efomethesine ?] temperature
[inaudible],, if I
have the same volume,
I have the same number
of [? particles. ?]
Now, what are those particles?
Oh, he was flexible.
This is important.
He was flexible.
He said, those particles
could be atoms,
or they could be
combinations of atoms.
They could be molecules.
Remember, at the
time, they hadn't all
settled on the atom
as a name, even.
What were these things?
Equal volume, same
number of particles.
And this really helped,
because you see,
if you make that assumption,
and you believe these volume
measurements, then it becomes
very clear what you have there.
Right?
If I have the same number
of particles in here,
and I believe in Lavoisier,
who tells me nothing
comes in or out in
terms of the math,
I didn't create
or destroy atoms,
then you know that if I
have two volumes of water,
let's say I started
with o and h.
It doesn't work.
I can't make enough water.
I just can't make
enough particles.
The number of
particles on the right
has to be equal to the
number of particles
in those two volumes of
hydrogen. It's got to add up.
Counting has to work.
That's what Avogadro gave
us is this idea of counting.
And that's why we've named
a constant after him.
So I'll get to--
Gesundheit or in honor
of Avogadro, "salu-tay".
[laughter]
He was Italian.
And so if you believe Avogadro,
if you believe Avogadro,
this becomes clear, because
the only way for these things
to work then is if
here I'm counting
how much volume's here.
So here I got HCL only if this
is a two, and that's a two--
diatomic gases.
That's the only way
the numbers work.
And here, I've got
to have two and two.
And this must be H2O.
Oh, or at least it's one
simple and very plausible
explanation if Avogadro's
hypothesis was right.
Dalton didn't buy it.
Dalton said, uh, uh, no way.
You've got leeks, dude.
And he really was harsh.
Everybody thought water
was OH at the time.
And so Dalton said, you
must have made a mistake.
I block you on Instagram.
[laughter]
I block you.
And it was pretty
tough, because Avogadro
put a lot of really
brilliant work
out there that was really
ignored for 50 years
until Cannizzaro came
along and others.
50 years later, two
years after he died
was when we had
the first evidence
that the scientific community
was willing to believe
that his hypothesis was right.
What a big deal his work was.
OK.
Now, I mentioned that this is--
I'm mentioning all
this because we
are going to use his constant
a lot, the Avogadro constant.
And it's a way--
and so I want to talk
about that constant--
and I want to do it in
the context of our candle.
And so because this
constant, this number,
this idea of the
number of particles
you have in chemistry is the
link between the atomic world
and the macroscopic world.
That's what his
constant does for us.
OK?
Now, let's put
that into context.
If I were to ask you a question
like this, I have that candle.
Remember, the
candle, the C25H52.
And I say, well, OK,
you've lit the candle.
How many candle molecules
burn in a minute?
I want to know that.
Don't we all?
Right?
That's a pretty
important question.
Why are people nodding?
Thank you for that agreement.
And I could say, well, I
assume the 12-hour candle
of the mass and 90
grams, let's get
that off of a candle on Amazon.
Right?
How many molecules
burn in a minute?
What I need to know
is, well, how many
are we sort of talking about?
How do we know how to
even answer this question?
And it comes from the link.
But see, to answer
this kind of question,
which I'm sure so many people
wanted to know back then,
you must have a way to
talk about big numbers.
You must.
Why?
Because there's a lot of these
molecules in a very tiny amount
of volume--
a lot.
Drop of water for perspective
has 10 trillion molecules--
10 trillion molecules.
Anybody know how many cells
you have in your body?
600 trillion?
Let's call it 100
trillion just to be nice.
Right?
It's a 100 trillion cells.
And so if you're going to talk
about how many cells you have,
or how many molecules
are in a drop of water,
you need to have a big
number, a big scale.
And that is what a mole is.
Avogadro didn't come
up with this number.
This was gotten
much later, right?
But we name it
after him in honor
of the work he did on
counting atoms and molecules.
And that's the number.
This is the way
we talk about it.
And just to be complete,
Avogadro's constant,
which is a mole, one mole
is equal to 6.022 times 10
to the 23rd.
It's just a number.
All right?
But it's a really important one
because it provides the link.
OK, if I take like how many
eggs are there in a dozen eggs.
It's 12.
How many bags of sugar are
there in a dozen bags of sugar?
It's 12.
All right?
How many atoms are there
in a mole of atoms?
That number.
That's all it is.
It's a number.
OK?
Oh, but a dozen eggs
weighs differently
than a dozen bags of sugar.
So a mole of one atom will
have a different amount
of mass, a different weight
than a mole of another atom.
And that's the link
that he gave us.
That's the link that
this number gave us.
And, in particular, again, going
back to this idea of counting,
we can count now with this link.
If I said, how many
pennies are there?
And I gave you a mass
of pennies, right?
If I had 2.5
kilograms of pennies,
and I say how many
pennies do I have?
Then all I need to know is
how much each penny weighs.
I'm not going to count them.
Right, you don't
want to count them.
You want to do something
a little easier.
So if I have one penny,
weighs 2.5 grams.
Then I know that I can just
get this really easily.
I have 1,000 pennies.
OK.
What a mole does--
a mole gives us the link.
So a mole, if I
have moles, then I
can go to the mass of an atom--
the mass of an atom.
And from that, I can go
all the way up to grams.
And this is critical.
OK.
The mass of the atom
and the grams per mole
are the same number.
That's what the mole gives us.
Right.
So in the case of
carbon, carbon has
a mass per atom of 12.011 AMU.
These are atomic mass units.
It's just a way
to measure things
that have very little mass.
But the link here is that if
I have a mole of these things,
if I have a mole, one
mole of carbon, then
I have exactly 12.011 grams.
Back and forth, grams, atoms.
Numbers of atoms, mass per atom.
All right, so one
carbon atom has
a mass of 12 atomic mass units.
We don't need to know.
This comes from weighing
neutrons and protons.
All right, we'll get
to that next week.
We don't even know that yet.
But this is a mass of things
that the very tiny scale.
And if I have a mole of
those atoms, I get to grams.
OK?
So it's my link.
Now, where is this amount?
Where is this
critical number that
gives me the counting per gram?
It's, of course, here
in your periodic table.
This is where you
get that information.
OK, so we'll be building
that up as we go.
Well, let's say why
do I need to count?
Well, let's go back to
answer our question now.
That's the link.
That number, Avogadro's constant
links these atomic masses
to grams.
All right?
Now I can answer the question.
How many candle molecules
burn in one minute?
Well, let's do that.
Because now I know
that one mole of C25H52
is something like 352.7 grams.
How do I know that?
Because I can look
up what a mole
weighs of carbon in
here, how many grams.
And I can look up how many
grams of mole hydrogen weighs.
And then I can
multiply 25 and 52.
And that's how many grams I get.
One mole of it is that.
Aha, the link is coming.
The link is coming.
It's very exciting.
Because in a 12-hour
candle, if it's 90 grams,
so if I have a 90 gram candle,
as I've said in the problem,
then I know now that
that is about 0.25 moles.
Right, because of this.
See that?
90 over that.
So now, I know how many
moles of candle I've got.
I know how many moles
of candle I've got.
But remember a mole
is just a number.
It's just a number.
So this is how many moles
of candle molecules I have.
And OK.
In one minute.
It says in one minute.
So in one minute--
well, OK, there's 60
minutes in an hour,
and it's 12 hours, just
a 720-minute candle.
Right?
So in one minute,
1/720 of that is what
burns, if it lasts 12 hours.
I'm just taking the
information I was given.
And I'm using the math
of minutes and hours.
1/720, OK.
All right, good.
So 1/720th of the candle burns.
In one minute, 1/720
of the candle burns.
And if the candle is that many
moles, that's this many moles--
0.003.
No, 0347 moles.
Why did I do all that?
Because I can now answer the
question, cause of Avogadro's
constant, because a
mole is just a number.
A mole is just a number.
So if I've got that
many moles, then I
know that I've got 2 times 10
to the 20th molecules roughly.
So I have been able to
answer this question
by going back and forth.
[inaudible]
I look here to get
the grams per mole.
I figured out how
much candle I had.
In grams, that gave me how
many moles I have of candle.
And then gave me the number--
back and forth, back and forth.
That's what we do.
Avogadro's constant gets us in
and out of the atomic world.
OK?
And so we're going to
practice that a little bit.
And this gets me back to
what we started on Wednesday.
And I always like to give
you guys advice if I can.
And last time I
mentioned, if you're
on a date at a restaurant,
ask them to give you,
not a candle, but some C25H52
as a test for the quality
of the restaurant.
[laughter]
Now, I'm asking you
to do something else.
It's noisy.
You want to talk.
Right?
You go out on a first date.
You're a little nervous.
You want a quieter room.
Ask them if there's a room where
you can kind of shut the door
and get that noise out.
And it's quiet so you can talk.
But now, you are armed with
very important knowledge,
because now, you know
how much volume you
have of air in the room and
therefore, how much oxygen you
have.
[laughter]
And if you light a candle, and
you're taken 10 to the 2 times
into 20 the molecules of
candle out of the year,
by the way, how many molecules
of oxygen are you burning?
Ah, how many
molecules of oxygen?
Ha, for at 38, balance--
38 times as many molecules.
For each one of
these that burns,
you need 38 molecules of
oxygen. So 38 times as many O2.
Now, I don't know about you,
but if I'm on this date,
I'm looking it up.
The human--
[laughter]
--needs 1.9 grams of
oxygen per minute.
You need that.
I mean, maybe it's variable.
But you need roughly--
and there's two of you.
0.4 grams of O2 is
burned per minute.
0 point-- who's going to win--
you or the candle?
So you got to be
just aware of this.
And now look, This is kind
of thing we can do now.
And I'm not saying
that everyone's
going to understand this.
You might not be
with an MIT student.
You might be with a student
from some other school
down the street.
[laughter]
All I want to say,
be nice, be nice.
It may not be their fault
that they're where they are.
[laughter]
It may not be their fault.
Go through this with them
carefully, slowly.
[laughter]
Explain these concepts.
And this gets me to the
other topic of conversation
that you can have.
And this gets me to my why
this matters moment for today.
Why does this matter?
Why does counting and thinking
about how much of stuff
you're using by using
chemistry and moles?
Why does that matter?
Well, let's take an example.
Let's take an example of
nothing less than the number
of humans on this planet.
This is the
population of humans.
And you can see that it wasn't
all that much until lately.
But let's focus in
on this part here.
Let's focus in on
that part there.
Right.
So that's billions of people.
So if I zoom in on
this, there's a change.
Look at that.
It's kind of going
a little bit up.
But now, it really kicks up.
What happened during that time?
What happened is a very
important chemical reaction,
became easy to do
or a lot easier.
OK?
And the process
that enabled that
is called the
Haber-Bosch process.
But it is what allowed
us to feed billions
of people in a sustainable way.
It's arguable whether we're
doing that sustainably
but in a way where we could
actually produce enough--
enough what?
Enough ammonia.
And here's the deal you see,
because plants need nitrogen
to grow.
Right?
And there's 70% of the
atmosphere is nitrogen.
But it's useless,
because it's N2.
And N2 is one of the
strongest bonds in nature.
And plants can't break it.
Now, we knew how
to break it before.
We knew how to do
this before, right?
This is called fixing--
fixing nitrogen. And the way
it works is you go N2 plus h.
This is a reaction, goes to NH3.
What is wrong with this?
[inaudible]
It's not balanced.
Thank you.
Did anybody say, balancing
is the same as mole ratio.
Balancing and mole ratio's
the same-- counting.
Remember, we talk about that.
But balancing is counting.
So let's see-- oh, 2 here.
OK, that helps me
with the nitrogen.
Oh, but this is H2.
I meant to put that
in the first place.
And then so this is a 3.
That reaction was
known and doable.
But it took tremendous
amounts of energy.
So it's very difficult to scale.
And Haber-Bosch came up
with a way using catalysis
to do it at much
lower temperatures.
Catalysis is something we'll
learn later in the semester.
But how do we answer
this question?
What's my question?
My question is how
long can we keep going?
50% of every protein
you put in your body--
50% come from this--
comes from some plant that
was grown using this process.
That's how important it is.
It's 500 million
tons of nitrogen
is made this way every year.
Well, it's just counting.
One mole of ammonia is 17 grams.
Oh, we're doing the same thing.
How did I know that?
Periodic table.
That's how I knew that.
One mole-- if that many
molecules of ammonia,
I've got 17 grams of it.
Let's say I just need to
make the same amount of--
it says so times
10 to the 6 tons.
I need that much
tons of NH3 per year.
That's our-- yeah, per year--
per year.
OK, so that sets up my problem.
I know how much I need.
I know how many atoms we're
talking about in one mole.
Now, I can actually
understand how many moles--
so I'm just going to
not do the detailed math
but how many moles I have.
So I've got 30 times
10 to the 12th moles.
This is how many moles
I needed per year.
How much do I have?
Well, we know how
much the atmosphere
weighs-- it turns out.
We know how much the
atmosphere weighs.
The mass of the atmosphere
is something like 5 times 10
to the 21st grams.
And if I take 78% of that
as my N2, so 78% is N2,
then I can tell
you that I've got--
let's see, 1.4 times 10
to the 20th moles of N2.
That's how much
I have available.
OK?
So if I keep on taking
N2 out of the atmosphere,
then I can now answer the
question just like the candle.
All right, how long do you have?
I can answer the
question, how long can we
keep taking N2 out
of the atmosphere
and using Haber-Bosch, right?
Oh, well, you would use
the balanced reaction.
So for every mole
event do I take,
I get two moles of ammonia.
That's good.
And you can work backwards.
And you can learn
that you're good.
We're good for now.
We have roughly
100 million years.
OK?
We have 100 million years
that we could keep consuming.
And then we'll run out
of N2 in the atmosphere.
How fun was that?
OK, I love doing this.
Now, when I get excited--
wow.
Wait, before I get excited,
what's the limiting reagent?
[? add ?] enough N2.
Is it N2?
How do you know?
How could you show?
How can you prove?
Limiting range, it means
what runs out first?
Well, oh, I'll just take H2
from the atmosphere, right?
Na, uh.
There's no H2 in the atmosphere.
Where's the H2?
Di da, it's over here--
H2O.
It's in the oceans.
How much H2O do I have?
Well--
[laughter]
It turns out you've got a lot.
10 to the 23rd-ish
moles of H2O, right?
10 to the 23rd-ish moles.
And so because of those
coefficients of the reaction,
you know exactly which one
is going to run out first.
You know it's N2, so your
answer over there was correct.
N2 is the limiting--
I love that little dance.
I'm going to try to learn that.
I'm going to learn that later.
If you try this, you
go 100 million years.
You run out of N2--
plenty of H2 left.
Let me read you.
When I get excited,
I didn't miss this.
I like to throw
stuff like T-shirts.
Now, the thing is these
T-shirts are not--
[laughter]
Now, and I go like this.
And then I go all the way--
ahh, to the back, all the way
up there, all the way up there.
All right.
OK, now look-- why
do I throw T-shirts?
I have no idea.
[laughter]
Sometimes things are
just better left unknown.
But please, I'll throw
T-shirts 34 more times.
Every lecture, I'm going
to throw some T-shirts
when I get a little excited.
And please, if you get a
T-shirt a second time, share.
Right, don't take it-- give
it to somebody-- trade.
Right?
Sharing is caring.
Now, where were we.
OK, now, here we are.
We got to build this?
Here's the thing-- in 1669,
there are only 12 elements
known.
But yeah, I hope I've
given you a sense.
All these people and many
more, I haven't even named.
We're working on
discovering new ones.
By 1799, we had 34.
Dalton and I mentioned
had a table of 36,
and they kept going.
And as we got more and more
elements, a lot of people
were wondering, how
do we organize these?
How do we organize these?
And are there patterns?
Are there patterns, right?
That became a hot question.
Yes, they still wanted to smash
and break and burn and make
new, discover new things.
But they also wanted to
know what it all means.
It wasn't just like
a few-- it was a lot.
And so they started
looking for patterns.
And one of the first
people was Dobereiner,
who came up with what he called
the Law of Triads, which was
a law that worked three times.
[laughs] But what he found--
[inaudible],, everybody was
arranging these elements
in different ways.
[inaudible] arrange it by mass.
No, arrange it by
something else.
And he found that if you
listed him kind of by mass-ish,
then the middle
atom of the three
would weigh exactly half or
roughly half of these two.
That was cool for three times.
OK, Newlands did something
really important.
Well, first of all,
he loved music.
And he arranged elements
like this and again, kind
of by mass.
And he noticed that there were
repeating patterns every eight.
Now, unlike a lot of triads,
this was really important,
because the Law of
Triads, you said,
look, I can take these three.
I can take those three.
That's kind of cool,
but it wasn't periodic.
It didn't happen these
three then, the next three.
And whereas the Newlands,
it was periodic.
And it sort of also only
worked for 2 and 1/2 runs.
The Law of Octaves--
he called it the Law of Octaves.
Oh, this was the time
to look for patterns.
And many people
took a stab at it.
Julius Meyer made some really
important contributions
in measuring the molar volume
by knowing the densities
and finding patterns.
they were looking
for periodicity.
But as many of you
may already know,
it was Mendeleev who figured
out what needed to be done.
And what he figured out
was absolutely critical.
Let's go to the middle.
And notice, he's listing them--
OK, he didn't know whether to
put it this way or sideways
or what.
This is oriented differently
than what we do today.
But it's OK.
He's just listing them
and looking for patterns.
But what Mendeleev did
that were so critical--
what he did that
was so important
is that he organized them.
So Mendeleev-- Mendeleev--
he had, at the time, this
was-- let's see 1869.
He had 63 elements.
And he called this
a periodic system.
And the critical piece is
he arranged them by mass.
And this is so
important-- properties.
He really believed that the
periodicity was the driver,
and that the properties were
critical in this organization--
the properties and the mass.
Right?
He was so certain that you had
to take them both into account
that he actually left gaps.
That was new.
At least for this many elements
and arranging it this way,
that was different.
And so like, for
example, look at this.
Over here, so here you
have aluminum, silicon.
And you know what else?
Uncover this, so you can it.
Oh, zinc-- OK, zinc.
Right, arsenic.
But he said, no, don't
just put this next to zinc
because of the properties.
This doesn't have
the right properties.
This should be more
like phosphorus.
So we're going to leave gaps.
And this is really important--
he predicted the properties
of those missing elements.
So if you call this, for
example, with silicon,
we know this is germanium.
We know that now.
But back then, no one had
smashed and burned and broken
enough stuff to find germanium.
So he said, well,
we can predict it.
Because it comes here in this
table in this organization,
therefore, it must
have properties
similar to other
elements in that column.
And he called it eco-silicon.
Eco just means one next, right?
And so these are predictions
by Mendeleev-- predictions
of the properties of
this missing element.
And here's what you get when you
actually find germanium years
and years later.
And you measure
those properties.
And look at that--
it's incredible.
Right?
Thank you for that wow
because I felt it too.
Any more T-shirts?
Aw, I felt the wow,
and it made me excited.
[laughter]
All right.
This is a big deal.
You go back to here--
iodine and tellurium--
no, I'm not
going to give you
the mass ordering,
because it doesn't make
sense in terms of property.
So I'm going to keep the mass
the other way, even though this
has a higher mass, look
at that question mark.
I'm still going to put it before
because it makes more sense.
That's what Mendeleev did, and
it was absolutely critical.
It really brings us to the
current system that we use.
So this is now the
periodic table.
Our periodic table today is
based Mendeleev's organization.
And we're going to be spending
a lot of time with it.
So we're not going to
go through everything.
But a couple of things.
First of all, there's a key.
That's the key to the table.
If a table doesn't have
the key, don't use it.
It should have a key.
And so, for example,
oh, look at that number.
That looks nice.
Right?
That's the AMU or the
grams per mole which we now
know are equivalent--
not equivalent but relatable.
You have a mole, that's
how many grams you have.
Or if you have one atom,
that's how many AMU's you have,
right there.
The key tells you
what things are.
Right?
Now, if you have a more
complicated one, don't panic.
Here's yours.
This is your periodic table.
Ha, look at this.
It's all in the key.
There's a lot more information
in here then in the basic ones.
But it's all in the key.
It's all described in the key.
And the key may be different
on the front and the back.
There may be different
properties included.
But it's all in the key.
And look at it.
Some of these we know
like the weight--
atomic weight-- that's what
we've been talking about.
Melting point sounds kind
of obvious-- boiling point
density.
And then you get to these other
things-- electronegativity,
first ionization.
All these things, what are they?
We will find out literally
next week, all right,
as we build up our
understanding of the atom.
But it's all on the key.
Now, this is so
important that I really
ask you with passion to carry
it with you everywhere you go.
I really do, because
you never know.
Remember the restaurant example.
You never know when you need it.
You never know.
And, in fact, you
can send me pictures.
Students do this.
I love it.
You don't have to
send me pictures.
You can just post it on your
feed or whatever it's called.
[inaudible]
What's it called?
I don't know-- a thing.
So they took it all the
way up to Dartmouth,
because there were some people
up there apparently that needed
help with their chemistry.
[laughter]
Here we are at a restaurant,
looking at the periodic table.
Here's another.
It's a good thing to
have at a restaurant.
You never know.
Here it is again.
Look at how happy they are.
Look at that, right?
They're really getting into it.
They're really getting into it
here, teaching family members
about this or being proud
of it with the whole family.
[laughter]
Take it with you.
It'll come in handy
no matter what.
Here it is under
a Christmas tree.
Right?
It's in here somewhere.
And there it is.
And look, even if you're
dressing up for a theater,
it's going to be important.
OK, now, this is the
one I want to get to--
OK, even if you're
a little tired.
It's going to be
what comforts you.
I think it's being
used as a pillow.
That's OK, it's comfortable.
Look at this.
[laughter]
Right?
You know even at the dance
club, even at the dance club,
oh, I see that.
You might need this.
You don't know.
Look at how happy he is.
[laughter]
Look at that,
because he has this.
Take it with you
everywhere you go.
Now, there's a bunch of
things about this table
that we'll be talking about.
We just built it up.
The first things is
just some nomenclature.
Right, just how
do we name things?
We name things that the
rose, we call them periods,
and there's seven of them.
The cones, we call them
groups, and there's
18 of them in the way
we organize, in the way
we present it, right?
But there's something
kind of important
that happens here which is
that these rows down here are
actually 14 elements longer.
So right, so this is 18 across.
But these guys
fit in right here.
They go right there.
Right?
These are called the lanthanides
because that's lanthanum--
innovative naming.
These are called the actinides.
OK.
They go in there in between.
Why don't we just
put it all there?
Well, you can.
But then you got the
bottom rows are 34.
Right?
And then the next one's up.
There's only two rows
in the periodic table
that are actually 18.
Then because then
you got 18 here.
And then these are eight.
And then you got two up top.
Now, why?
That we will understand
when we understand the atom
a little better next week.
OK?
But for now, I just want to
call your attention that these
are the names that we use.
And those top ones
are called mean group.
These ones are
transition elements.
You have alkalines here.
You have lanthanides, actinides.
These are the names that
we give these regions that
get more clear when we
know what electrons are.
And I think I'll tell
you just the last bits
about just a couple
more observations
about the periodic
table, I think,
when we start our lecture
on Monday since it's 11:54.
And as promised, I want to
let you guys out right on time
every lecture.
Have a fantastic weekend
and see you Monday.